hi my name is Jeff Qin I'm the chief
coffee guy groundwork coffee and this
morning we're going to try one coffee
brewed over several different methods
and discuss the differences we taste
that those methods bring out of the
coffee come on into my playground
so I'm Liz I'm an artist so I drink a
lot of coffee from all over the place
I'm not an expert but I do taste a lot
I'm Geoff chief coffee guy I guess the
resident expert so I'm kind of the
coffee snob around the office I worked
with coffee before I've worked in a
couple of different coffee shops things
they have a professional relationship
with coffee I talk a lot of coffee game
and I'm kind of here to see what I
actually know this is the Chemex brewer
developed by a very bored chemist was up
late at night during World War two Jeff
I did not like that one clean coffee
flavor
it's like shitty diner coffee this is
called the clever dripper this is a full
immersion brewing shoe yeah I would I
would say yeah not a lot of oh did you
taste some shoe in there is some shoe
that was kind of boring like a saucer
forever yeah rich black right like like
a Beverly Hills housewife yeah French
press seen this around everywhere got a
very very body taste see more dish it's
more of an amber yeah you're absolutely
right yeah I wouldn't be surprised to
find like an ancient mosquito in here I
think this is the French press I could
drink this black all right this is the
control that we're gonna use this is a
mr. coffee made famous by Joe DiMaggio
tasting some soil as I normal this I'll
say is shitty I felt this is definitely
the darkest of the three so far tastes
like it's uh wasn't extracted properly
I'm gonna say these two were watery this
is the boldest for me pareo v60 it's
Japanese Japanese culture has a long
history of love with coffee
you got a great dangle that's the way
angle of my dangle it's like good or
diner
I felt like kind of watery not very
strong left me again with a little bit
of a flat line leaves a nice flavor in
my mouth I'm getting a little flavor I'm
getting a little it's a little heavier
okay well I'm obviously correct so where
did you go wrong on this tasting right
now
Aeropress is made by the guy who made
the aerobic flying disc it tastes kind
of like burnt coffee I could sense
coffee but mainly like the shadow of
coffee it's a it's coating the tongue
but it's not really it's not really
liven up the party right I didn't hit me
like um you know like a punch all right
watch out major skin in the game cuz
again I talk a lot of coffee game at
BuzzFeed so so this is a potential
source of huge embarrassment for you
yeah I'm liking this one the best
okay so again this was my favorite I'm
sticking with my French press and mr.
coffee choice we go alright oh [ __ ] yeah
sorry French press er chemic I just
really hope you fix mr. coffee why no no
anything you think mr. coffee is your
fave
this is you've messed up you have messed
up with your order wow man even you're
such a plea but you didn't even know it
my life has been upended the fact that I
chose mr. coffee is number one is
ridiculous
gonna walk upset now no I'm not gonna
walk off set its yeah a real mature
no that's great